I just wanted to say
that, um,
we've all made
terrible decisions,
but this'll be a good one
and I'm so honored
to be here
celebrating this
beautiful couple.
So everybody,
let's raise a glass
to love,
laughter,
and welcoming
a new baby into this world.
(crowd gasps)
#
Um...
I'm so sorry.
Cheers! Yeah!
#
(scattered applause)
So good.
You guys...
I--she can't be the one bride
that's gained weight
for her wedding, right?
-I mean, she's already showing.
-Totally.
Oh my God, you guys,
was it that bad?
Oh yeah, it was really bad.
I'm, like, kind of
attracted to you right now.
Todd!
Okay, okay,
it wasn't as bad
as our wedding ceremony.
-You remember?
-Bad!
That was the best.
I, personally, had a great time.
-Really?
-I loved it.
Good, I wept
through our honeymoon.
Lucy, I will love you,
honor you,
cherish you.
I will...
Um...
(clears throat)
You are my inspiration
to stay in shape
and we will go to the gym.
We will get memberships
together and...
Oh, I totally forgot
about that.
-See?
-Yeah, and we got over it.
I...kinda didn't.
Remember, I'm still
in therapy?
You're in therapy
for a million other reasons.
-Can we not do this here?
-Nope, yeah, that's--yeah.
It wasn't as great
as the time Milo had
the little jaunt
down Romance Lane.
-Oh God.
-Oh, that's right.
Are you talking about what
I think you're talking about?
Yeah.
#
(music stops, crickets chirping)
Come on, Milo.
Pick it up!
I'm married.
Pick it up, Milo!
Fine! Okay.
I'm getting married!
(cheering)
Hey Milo.
You have to go put it on him,
it's tradition.
Oh...
Where?
Let's do it!
Woo!
(cheering)
That guy was a stud.
Such a stud.
Remember the farm fiasco?
Oh, that was fun!
-That was fun.
-Farm pics.
That was insane.
(twangy music plays)
Nice, dude!
This is the wrong wedding.
Yeah, we have to go.
The hooch? What?
Oh, you guys, this way.
Come on.
-Love it.
-It's leaving, run!
(car engine roaring)
-Wait, wait, wait, wait!
-Wrong wedding! Wait!
Well, that shuttle won't be back
for at least an hour.
-Ooo, I know what we can do.
-Come on, take the picture.
Come on. Come on.
Oh! Oh!
Stop this!
I hate this!
You wanna come
live with me?
He's peein' on your dress.
-What?
-Just an FYI.
Oh my gosh, okay.
(pig squeals)
Shh.
Go! Ah!
Please stop it.
Hey! What're you guys doin'?
-Uh...
-Get outta there!
-Sorry!
-I'm sorry.
Sorry about that.
Man.
Those stupid chickens.
Baked chicken.
Oh!
Really?
(groans)
Can I have your broccoli?
A-tink-tink-tink-tink-tink.
Hot mic.
Hi y'all, I'm Jeff,
I'm Brian's good friend
from college.
Uh, before I congratulate
the happy couple over here,
I just wanted to tell
all of y'all
about this Crowdstarter
fundraiser I just launched.
It's for a graphic novel
I just wrote
called "The Blood Oath
of The Wrathners."
Let me tell you about
what the Wrathners are--
-I do not feel so bad anymore.
-These things...
-...are centuries' old...
-I think you're in the clear.
-Oh yeah.
-...vampires who also rap.
Do you think he's single?
And these basketball playin'
vampires,
they bite rubber.
Do not date that guy.
I'm not making promises.
Just one second. Your grandmama
is lovin' it, okay?
Let me tell ya, this is--
this part's for you.
You're gonna love this.
All right, so--